you may think that walking through walls
is impossible but have you ever heard of
quantum tunneling
it's a real thing that i don't
understand so i'm about to have a
two-minute elevator ride with a quantum
physicist who's going to tell me what
it's all about
so tall
[Music]
hi chris hi
so i've learned a little bit about
quantum entanglement before and it was
pretty confusing please tell me quantum
tunneling is a bit easier yes you've got
45 floors up and down so let's do it
what is quantum tunneling okay first i
want to give you this thank you if i
take that ball and throw it at the wall
what will happen that's back it'll
bounce back it doesn't have enough
energy to go through the wall i want you
to imagine that as a proton yep
[Music]
so now we're talking about quantum
mechanical things it's not a ball it's a
fuzzy blob of probability okay
how can something be a probability well
what it means is that it's not here or
here or here here but it could be spread
out in the possible locations and if you
wait long enough you could find it
anywhere
okay
sure all right so
so a single proton could be anywhere
could be anywhere but they're more
likely places it can be and these places
are vastly more likely if you take any
one proton and you kind of trap it say
within your experimental device it'll
probably stay there forever but if you
did that a billion times then one time
you'll find one that has left
if you think about it
as a ball then there's a barrier that it
can't pass it doesn't have enough energy
but when we think about it as a
probability sometimes even though the
probability's small it will end up on
the other side of the wall so when they
do we say that they've tunneled
through this repulsive barrier
okay i will accept that for now
we're halfway through all right
is tunneling useful for anything it's
happening all the time so without
tunneling well we wouldn't really have
anything but i thought it was all about
probability and it's really rare
to happen it's rare for an individual
object but it's common because there's
always lots of quantum objects around if
you have lots and lots and lots of
protons like for example at the center
of the sun there's just the right amount
of probability so that enough fusion is
happening
to well
let us be here i thought the pressure
and heat in the sun was enough to just
make fusion happen even in at the center
of the sun all of that heat all of that
energy doesn't give the protons enough
energy to overcome the repulsive force
so
nuclear fusion is caused by quantum
tunneling yes does tunneling always
cause fusion tunneling generally is just
something that we call a quantum
explanation for an event that happens
due to the quantum chance once you dig
down deep enough
and try to find deep enough description
of anything that biological processes in
your body how you smell how you see you
have a computer in your phone it has
lots of transistors these are a few
nanometers across if you want to explain
it at the level of the individual atoms
that are carrying out these reactions
you need quantum mechanics and those
will all be based on tunneling
probabilities
on a scale of one to ten how much do we
as a human race understand about quantum
tunneling uh i would say we've tunneled
through ten we're at eleven really
okay our entire modern world is is based
on our understanding of quantum
all right well i have some thinking to
do thanks chris you're welcome and
thanks for my proton
my proton
[Music]
you know every time we talk quantum
physics it's really confusing but
thankfully i had chris to walk me
through it okay so there are quantum
particles everywhere and they exist in
this realm of probability they're not in
a fixed location they could be in a
number of locations in fact they could
even be in an improbable location they
can be in locations that they don't have
the energy to be in for example protons
overcoming electromagnetic repulsion to
come together in nuclear fusion they
shouldn't be able to do that traditional
physics can't explain it and that's
where we use the term quantum tunneling
but funnily enough as improbable as it
is it's actually happening everywhere
inside our own bodies in our smartphone
even in the sun
now i am still a little bit fuzzy on the
details though just like a quantum
particle
hey thanks for watching if you're
curious about our universe then you are
going to love our documentary series
catalyst we'll put more details down
below or you can click here for some
shorts and don't forget to subscribe to
this channel for more videos see ya